hey 42 here the London Underground has
made more money from its famous map than
it ever has from running trains welcome
to RIF in 2010 the Italian government
had a fleet of six hundred and twenty
nine thousand official cars ten times as
many as the US government Mars is
populated entirely by robots 7 to be
precise about a quarter of the world's
hazelnuts a hundred thousand tons a year
are used to make Nutella Sudan has more
pyramids than Egypt more than a third of
the world's 43,000 794 airports are in
the USA star box offers 87 thousand
different drink combinations the heart
symbol was first used to denote love in
1250 prior to that it represented
foliage in 2012 a Somali Islamist
militant group offered a bounty of 10
camels for President Obama and 2 camels
for information on Hillary Clinton the
dinosaur noises in the Jurassic Park
movie were made from recordings of tor
toys sex the first recorded instance of
air rage involved a passenger in first
class who shat on the food trolley after
being refused another drink eight of the
Earth's 88 naturally occurring chemical
elements were discovered in the same
mine in Sweden the first known vending
machine dates back to the 1st century AD
it accepted a coin then dispensed holy
water
40% of all bottled water sold in the
world is bottled
up water humans have been
hunter-gatherers for 99 percent of their
history the US has only 5% of the
world's population but almost 25% of its
prison population thanks for the view
subscribe for more for CJ